hi everyone it's Jerry I'm going to hop
into an hourly super Blitz Arena
bit of an unusual time for me to
hop into an arena it's 8 A.M for me
December 16th
so let's see what we get here my mouse
was just doing some weird stuff right
there
okay A bit of a rocky start
let us see
all right right out of the opening here
at Dutch
let's try Bishop G5
had a
pretty smooth game recently with this
ended up
double doubling my opponent's pawns I
still could have actually done that
straight away
but we'll go for this
I'll put this guy here
nothing sophisticated
this is a welcome Exchange
and
I think I'm I'm already gonna look to
maneuver
so
eventually I want this guy right here
uh I think I should hop in now he's not
easily challenged with the bishop on D7
additionally I have this move to kick
the night out of my house
okay
I think
I think I just want to support it
I don't want to play F4 so soon
because I then the night could hop in
here
hold my ground
the night could still happen here uh
he's found a roundabout way to get in
there
but I think I should still be better
maybe maybe not actually I'm forgetting
that this bishop
could potentially go here
I'm thinking I should resolve this
tension
or
hmm
let's go with this move first
stop Bishop H5 I have G4 it's committal
I think I may want to give in time do
this stuff
okay so much for that
okay let's prepare to double
or not actually
hmm
foreign
okay let's try this
and this one I want to try to carve out
a square on D4
surprised that that actually capturing
the bishop gets a square
but
so does my name
okay
hmm
not really sure how to assess this one
I think the bishop is going to be able
to get here
not too much I could do about that
my Knight's gonna be pinned okay I know
I'm losing my B Pawn
I'm just hopeful that my knight could do
something dangerous
Rook is pinned I'm on the pawn
and I may be winning The Rook actually I
think A5 will be necessary at some stage
with this nearby
or that defending the queen directly but
now I have the better Miner
might as well go here
and defend this Pawn there could be a
sacrifice in this square at some stage
just want to go somewhere where my Rook
is my queen is active
probably best to neutralize this Rook
before there's some coordinated effort
on G2
slightly behind on the clock
so this guy is all in as an aggressor
so if I could sneak Behind Enemy Lines
I'd like that
so I think this is a perfect start
and then this I'll have three attackers
okay
this is coming pretty fast
think the queen really needs to harass
my Rook
my queen gets here with my Rook stable I
think there's a problem
I'm gonna go for that
okay
all right let's try here actually there
isn't a my knight is covering oh there's
still
there's still Queen here right
we're gonna have a rat race
I'm gonna go somewhere else
okay I'm officially kicked from the
second
let's get here
get behind the pawn
win the pawn and then go back
to Target E6 12 seconds each
gotta hurry
so the bishop isn't able to oh it is
helping right now
looking for this break
okay wow that was a really tight first
game
I really like the first game
all right that's unusual
Bishop two
G5 move two
uh all right we'll go back
when this guy is still live
when it has it has still has a move
I don't like working with double death
Pawns
because my Center could quickly come
under Fire
this is my Expendable Bishop
don't mind if he's hunted with the
with a knight
that was something similar going on in
this game
weakness on e4 I'd like to get to
in time
maybe a bit slow
actually
let me start with this move
that way when this night Lions here it's
with tempo
okay so much for that
you have to be careful of my H file for
sure
okay
let me take once I think I might want to
take a second time
yeah I'd end up getting forked
and Knight is such a pest
okay
not sure how to untangle I should be
worse here and I am
I should be worse and I am
I'm not even threatening this because of
the fork
there could be an accident happening
very soon
I like that I'm at least covering
against the battery this this idea
though is scaring me
I'm not sure what I'm doing to defend
against that
tough day for me here maybe only after
G4 do I make this commitment taking the
Knight and then drop the queen on
G5 and hope for a queen exchange I guess
in time I'm
trying to get a break in
with B4 oh
Brute Force stuff
I see
fancy
fancy fancy
yeah
you have a point
okay what do I do oh I could take here
and maybe go here
um
let's take here first
The Rook has to take I guess
otherwise I get this and I'm out of any
pins
so The Rook isn't
the greatest here but they're still
better is this
there's so much on F5
oh they might be thinking about the
in-betweener
I wouldn't mind that though at least I
get an open file I could trade a
stupid Rook on f8
passive Rook
there's some other in-betweener
I guess you could consider this one as
well
I think all these are good
opponents at least in the tank
head on the clock but I think I'm just
worse here
a couple good moves by white and
I should be a gunner so yeah this move
and reply to it
I'm not sure what I'm supposed to even
do
not even sure what I'm supposed to do
so
I guess take once
and then I was thinking I have to play
here maybe I could play G6
maybe G6 is the way
opponents again thinking
okay
I think I have to try this try and hold
my light squares
again if there's some sacrifice there's
tension here
at least I have some hope of maybe
Landing a check
okay what about here seems healthy
barely held together by a thread
barely barely barely
Cairo Knight here defends this
sacrifices here don't seem to be working
I am in a pin but I have this
my time
of course there's that
scrolling up into a ball
bye now
careful
wow rat race
um
I'm not too happy about those games
that was not a
yeah could have very easily lost both of
those so let's see if I could get a
clean game in
okay E4 where am I I got four points I
don't know how
these Pliers are
flying up there 11 and 10 it's 43
minutes
all right let's see
I think I'll just leave that guy out
there up for grabs
maybe maybe
one day I'll grab a pawn I'll just wait
to be kicked okay there really isn't
anything wonderful then to come back and
stay Central
now with the half open D file
well actually
yeah with the half open default I'm
thinking about Queen side castles and
also I want to duck The Exchange because
this is landing
I think pretty much the night needed to
go here to stop this power horse
you got a four coming up
not much they could do about that
it's even worse now
King rook and queen Fork
just get out of any silliness on the C
file
okay
we'll cut out the night jumps
and try and kick this bishop off the
long diagonal could have also grabbed
the pawn a lot of ways to do it
that was better
all right
anyway you should get the job done
of this material
pry open and pry open a file
and keep going
keep on pushing
okay
should be just made in a few
okay they resigned
I got eight
five thirty six in there popular time on
leeches
okay it's gonna be tough to track these
guys down I'm not really in the
berserking mood
rarely am
let's try Sicilian
I think I'm encountering
I'll be encountering some players that
I've never played before
playing at this
different time
okay
um take a step out to stop the the pin
this is an important
minor piece
to watch over the
big weakness on D5
standard setup here the nidorf
expand on the queen side
so this move both of these moves
actually could turn out to be
waste
a waste
because there's no guarantee they they
open up
it's actually difficult
to
you know there's not a clear plan for
why
um a strong Center I'm watching over
this weak point I'm not going to Castle
so soon because that that's actually
giving way
something something to think about
something to bite out
an imbalance with the Rook lift
like to avoid being attacked
I can
but we hop in here
I'd prefer to hunt this guy that's the
better Bishop so
probably should have sat on that one
I have space on the queen side now that
there isn't this battery I feel more
comfortable castling
additional benefit with this space is I
have the bishop
coming to C5
that wasn't working straight away
because my queen would have been
overloaded
okay there's pressure here
um this Knight's unprotected
suppose I go here there's Queen takes
my first thought was this one
really don't like taking the pressure
off of this point
let's see if I take take
Knight takes
a little calculation
I'm sorry takes takes takes takes then I
have Bishop
to D4 forking these two but that's
defended
hmm
all right let's just weasel around
enough to be in a rush
okay
[Music]
um
let's go here
I guess I'm with this move saying
if the Knight drops in here I'm going to
take but it was only up two squares so
hmm you could change the structure
now let's go here
not winning a piece because I could end
up in a pin but I could get out of the
PIN
and hit something else so I think I am
tracking upon
we'll be winning some material right
here I don't take
take and I have to worry about my knight
I want to get the E4 Pawn
then consolidate
achieve a harmonious position where
everything's defended ideally
okay Knight is hopping in how jumpy is
that this guy oh I didn't see that
Okay so
they're on this point so I guess I take
at this stage
put this Knight on a good Square
I'd like a queen Exchange
Knight defends the base point
okay and probably get rolling right
about now with the majority
I'll take with the pawn no I gotta take
with the Knight
oh Queen there
okay let's defend
It's Tricky still
I didn't see that move
that pawn will be one down if it's the
king and pawn ending so
and apply it like this put pressure on
the pawn this might be tempting but
there's me
to defend the pawn all right so I'm
getting this guy
and still defending the pawn let's hide
let's go here and just stay really
active
this there's the
could have probably played G6 without
fear of Queen takes H6 but still
let's just do it like this
and slowly improve my queen while there
was a similar mate
like when uh if G4 was played earlier
okay
we got 12.
35 to go
I want to see let's play a carocon
okay
um okay we'll go Mainline
that one
okay let's play with E5
Queen A5 idea
I don't know if this is such a wonderful
plan
maybe just flat out bad why am I doing
this
why am I doing this
no
I have a bad position at least let's
grab a pawn
another one
yep
they should play like that shouldn't
they
setting up discoveries
so I'm on two pawns but I'm way behind
in development
there's no Rook be one
uh in some variations I was concerned
about this F Pawn rushing hmm
fancy
fancy
all right maybe I go Queen side castles
still have to be very careful
maybe I could cut this out
C5
release some pressure I'm not sure how I
finished developing honestly
may have to bail out
give up a piece just to get tucked away
something to keep in mind
I do have the two Pawns
all right what am I doing if the queen
is attacked probably continuing Pac-Man
form
grab another piece upon
at least my opponent's in the tank
I don't like how I'm playing this game
either
maybe I shouldn't play it this time
today
okay
yeah oh hang on
Bishop C4
whatever let's grab another one
let's take everything I want to keep
pressure on something
so defend the night doubt I have time
for that
okay
I think I'm close to
wanting to just castle and play the
three Pawns
for the peace and balance
can I save the night
um
maybe this is a start
yeah let's go with this one
I think it's still hang on to the night
for a little bit and my queen weasel
around
uh my queen can't be kicked so much I
don't think
buy a thread
I'm hanging on
we're gonna go Queen side give up the
piece the Queens come off and then my
king is around to support these passers
I like that choice I think
yeah let's
let's be careful
let's go for this
more trades I think the more pieces that
come off the better
these three pawns shine
all right
there's no H3
background could be a problemo
good coordination Knight versus three
pawns and now is the time to do what
probably start there
hit the bishop
let's not give up
let's continue to harass this guy
where are you going
there to there and I have a big lead on
the clock
okay
so I could take that Bishop
and
I said I was a fan of Trades but I also
like my knight
help support this guy
let's keep them around
maybe now I take
now keep pushing
take away oh okay that one
and see that happening
oh I have this
maybe I should have consider that in the
last move
not afraid of any checks I could hide
I want to stop that check run these two
and step up
should be winning this on the clock
maybe even on position
more trades
I'm just throwing away the pawn aren't I
yeah that pawn could have been won
let's just make any move
okay
I should probably play that one
different
more bad games than good so far
okay wow
the 724 in there still 29 to go I got
16. the king is in first
all right we'll try to get into confetti
Zone
top three
okay
are they reacting
no shove no E4
um
yeah I'll just go one
I don't want to take the Knight
just yet
D5 this there's a double attack but
Bishop B4 is there
I think I guess I'll take now
the hand Castle
I don't mind if this this happens
because the Queens would come off and
then this is a glaring weakness in the
end game
okay
I need to finish developing developing
so let's go with this one
this is always a
possibility although I think the timing
is not right
because of Knight A4
and I kick the Bishop from defending D4
so that seems like a little bit
comes off as a slow move
okay
so if I take now
you gotta take here
let's do this
and I'm gonna hopefully look to play
against the hanging Pawns
let's start with this move
this would be
a welcome exchange I think best is this
to be irritating now my queen achieves a
monster post
and I could start pinpointing these
hanging pawns it's
it's a position that's
quite simplified
and this is a good news for me the more
simplified the position playing against
the hanging pawns the better
this is a necessity I believe
otherwise this is a long-term Target and
this is stable
okay now this is Rock Solid and it's
much much much easier to play this
position is why because of this detail
and I have to babysit B4 I could focus
on
C6 with all of my pieces basically
and I could have played this actually
before my last move
tracking this guy
but
I actually feel that
no matter what I should be able to win
upon
so
I'm not gonna rush it
okay well let me let me revisit now that
I have the flight Square in
let's calculate a little bit
yeah I want I think I just want my
Bishop here this would be
this would be good news so I mean
there's pins here I have an E4 break I
have this still on the cards
three attackers two Defenders I'm ready
to add
a fourth and it won't be able to be
defended
okay let's go in for this finally
E4
all right swap oh I was thinking maybe
this but that would fall
it's very difficult now
so I believe I could just chop away
May soon be up a pawn and
with uh an active Rook
I am in a pin so I'm not threatening to
take
maybe rookie rookie eight
yeah actually what am I doing against
that
I guess let's defend like this and maybe
even
go here
take with the queen
okay I got a passer a connected passer
The Rook is very active
I also have this
I could pinpoint F7
Bishop there here
try and kick the The Rook away let's
start with the PIN
okay that's not
working because I have this
and let's take just win the king and
pawn ending my Pawn is not fast enough
to score on his own
Pawn is ready to bolt
way too fast
and try some stalemate tricks
all right there's plenty of time in the
tank here
all right
Bishop A3 would have been a much much
different game
uh berserk I guess we'll try berserk
back
Scandinavian
oh I had this did I play this player
for
okay I had a game room not too long ago
just the other day
it's gonna say that the queen can't go
here because this idea to break the pin
is no longer available
A6 Bishop A4 the Knight is lost
okay let's take the material
maybe I could have been
a bit more irritating playing
first E6
hinting at this now
Bishop there there's a problem
common saccharoni
just come back to home base
I don't want to be stopped from castling
and I'll leave that night there for a
bit
okay
grabbing all the material
and here Queen here is me
I was thinking Queen F5 first that would
drop the bishop
and that was a fast one
22 minutes
8 16 in there
okay
somebody anybody
I'm okay Oblivion
let me go for a king's Indian uh so much
for that
playing
London
there
okay
well I don't want to cut out any Knight
B5 stuff
opponent appears to know what they're
doing
uh I guess take first
okay
I'm already worse
much worse
why are they taking with the pawn
I don't know what that one's about I am
defended here so
let's go here
this is an opening disaster at least
there's some deficiency on the king's
side
they just took with the bishop they
still have this plan
on the queen side and I have the zip
they maintain a perfect structure
across the board
I'm actually winning a pawn if they
there's no time to immediately recapture
my Knights there
it's not the most healthy Pawn around
anyhow my last move I want to challenge
this guy
it's one that's in my house or they
might might be calculating a sacrifice
come to think of it
let's see
all the more reason now to challenge
this guy straight away
Okay so
now they are ready for this and there
really isn't anything I could do about
it
they're going to have the open file
I gotta you gotta tame that Bishop
before it's too late
okay let's go here I don't want to mend
the structure
as mentioned
this is the only thing I have going for
me
ideally
I'd like to
you know take and maybe maybe in this
way now
um
I'd still be repairing the structure
somewhat
um
let's hold my ground
okay I'm gonna be giving a kick soon oh
how about this maneuver
yeah you know what maybe maybe I put my
knight on this Square
or
could I go with the slower approach I
wonder
just thinking for a second I could take
the pawn on C4 not the case
okay maybe preparing a check
How concerned am I about that
go here maybe
I don't think I'm too concerned about
the check
maybe I should have been
and I could go over here
I'm on The Rook I might have to make a
really passive move soon
I want to stop that yeah they're they're
thinking the Nike has to take
so thought that crossed my mind too
okay well
playing more bad than good
Neil
uh let's try French this time around
only this man these tournaments fly all
right exchange French
I like that move
I'll do similar
no Greek gift because I have Bishop F5
to defend
okay probably cut this out
yeah let's cut this one out
does a good job of
stopping the night jumps as well
let's go hunting for a bishop
oh you know what
I should have focused more on just
getting rid of their better Bishop
okay let's not take
let's get this maneuvering
Bishop takes Bishop
I think I'll take with the Knight
okay
how about this
this is covered
this is covered
that's a good move
standard strong setup here by white
okay let's take
they could consider capturing here
my idea is to step up to F7 hopefully
I'm not gonna get hurt
this seems like the most convenient
defense of G6
yeah
and this is this is a move that
is concerning
okay let's see if I could
get some pieces off
I have to play some defense so that I
could have eased
this pressure if I didn't try and go
hunting for the dark Square Bishop
instead just try to get rid of the light
Square Bishop
okay they could try some exchange sack
one way or the other
now I'm prepared to run
in case they go for that
night here I think I might okay that one
guess I take
and try this
hey yep
okay hopefully
hopefully
this
doesn't get broken down
this square is a hole but my dark Square
Bishop is watching out for it maybe I
could throw in an aggressive move
be my first of the game
Queen H4 targets a pawn doesn't threaten
mate at the moment
but it's something to keep an eye on I
don't see any deficiency with
getting a rook to an open file Queen on
F6 should guard
a nice
group of squares on the king's side
not threatening the pawn
they have to watch out for the back rank
potentially
you know I could guard these flights
that flight Square
Bishop is already indirectly there
okay well let's let's go here
my first threat Queen takes Pawn
not sure how it's defended
I don't have any wonderful discoveries
just uh
Bishop D7 so I could play Bishop D7 now
and isn't my opponent overloaded
with the queen
now let's go here
might have been some night move
okay
give him a kick
no discoveries as far as I could tell
um
let's go here
keep pressure on F2
all right let's go here central
if that Queen H6 I always have some
block to safeguard my king
all right let's go after that
H2 Square oh
they're allowing me to get there
now we got something dangerous
discoveries
okay oh I could go here and then take
the Knight would check
no time to take with check
go back here for almost mate
for almost mate
might have more discoveries
there there
another bishop move
grabbing the queen soon okay
Under 12 I think this guy just finished
so I should be getting that pairing
I think
okay let's try D4
no catching this guy it's up 16.
the king
all right
I like my position
[Music]
hopefully this could be one of my
better games
um
okay sure
take with the queen I get to the back
rank if they go for this break I think
they're in an eternal pin now
I'm just recognizing that
it's Rook there
so they're gonna try to be a pest
with their this move under mining my
knight
got it
all right
okay
let's go here
got a file watching out for this
intersection Square I still need a
flight Square
I think that's the the best one
I'm even gonna go to
and see how I don't see how to improve
my pieces
or my Rooks I should say in my Bishop
but
focused on Pawn play
okay
maybe some checks maybe Rook B4
maybe I should have played that a little
sooner
okay this could be an idea
okay let's go here first
um
okay let's take
it like that wow
okay so let's try and get here what is
my Rook not hitting if I get there
I think I'm winning upon
I have a cozy King
I could try to simplify the position get
rid of the tricky Knight
I'm gonna do that
okay I'll take and try to win this
ending up a pawn I still have something
to bite at
maybe I should have played here before
that
sneak over to the center
King wants to be here
I could threaten mate
something like that cutting the king off
as soon as oh they just resigned
okay
I don't know
I guess it was winning
they were on their back foot no active
plan
but it seems still a little bit early
okay
this one should count
all right let's see if I could play this
one a little bit better
this
this happened last time
okay let's go here Knight C3 again not
Knight C3 in this case
okay
Bishop F5 is met with Pawn takes Pawn
the nice
move that I've
uh
have messed up with that missed that
idea many times then Blitz
okay
this should be a problem
okay
how sidelined is my knight
pretty sidelined all right let's go here
I'm actually recalling a game from a
recent stream where I ran stockfish
versus
um
Leela
played a couple games
stockfish with white
anyhow in this Pond was here Leela
ended up maneuvering the night like this
as a defense on the king's side not
exactly this structure but
I think it could end up just out of Play
If I go here
the pawns alone control the night from
getting back in the ball game and
additionally my Rook is no longer seeing
my opponent's side of the world
meanwhile
my clock continues to tick let's go here
I have a square for my knight I'm also
stopping castling although I don't think
they were
really going to Castle there
yeah
I think it's more about the night move
okay I do not mind seeing this I'm going
to take with my less Central night
and I think I want to open it up first I
don't mind seeing this
okay so now I take like this one
and now
probably
Queen side castles
I'd like to get a rook here on F5
let's get off of the half open file
and put the Rook on the half open file
again I'm now thinking about something
with the queen
a queen on F5 could be really irritating
what are they looking to do not sure
maybe C4
there's only one way in along a diagonal
but that's easily offset with Rook C7
I have the healthier structure that's
the the big difference in this position
as far as I could tell I have a check
let's improve the bishop
and check clean here maybe bishop E3
well if I track this Pawn down there
maybe counter play
maybe this is a
a good move to get in
could also think about hunting the
h-pawn
this is the one I would prefer to get
um
I could try for it right now or
just make a healthy move this this would
have been better
okay let's go here first let's take into
step two
Safeguard my king this construction very
very healthy okay so now there's a
disconnect with the Rooks
my queen is
being a queen for sure
to watch out
I've missed
stuff like this we are opposite and they
miss that I'm on The Rook there
okay
I resigned all right
this should be the final game will
account for the tournament
and we will see
all right and we will also see if it's a
grundfeld or King's Indian or none of
the above
looks like a benko
I'm gonna take and play this
not uh
a setup I have a ton of experience with
okay what's the move okay I think it's a
four
trying to recall I've been running these
bot battles
starting at a specific positions
and this is one of the the variation I
was looking to learn a little bit more
about
okay
in the castle
I'm gonna take with the pawn I think
and I want to see this Knight drop in so
easily and unleash that Bishop
um you know what yeah I'm gonna go with
this I'm also stopping the night from
getting here
okay so they're not taking
think
this is cool
Bishop on D2
watch this Pawn doesn't fall
anyone is flicking H3 okay I guess no
no no no no
Knight C4
okay I'm still gonna I'm still gonna
play here
here's this idea
hoping to get the pawn back though if
they go in for this
and get on C4
we'll see
give it a move I think I want to play E4
let's take here
two connected passers seems like they
are going for this
win of the pawn
again E4 if they're not taking straight
away
I think this is this should be winning
for me
the more it simplifies the more these
guys show up
two connected passers
my Bishop stops any Queen A5 moves so if
we chop away Queen can't get Super
Active okay we are having this this
taking the pawn hitting the Knight
let's try and be a pest with the queen
Knight B6 Queen C6
Bishop A5 idea
although here
Queen B8
no no no
still go here
clean B8 there's Rook C8
okay probably simple
doubling or
maybe improve the Knight
or flight Square
what do I want to do
let's get a flight Square in
let's stop the doubling
it could be a fork on B2 that's what
kept me from doing that
one move sooner that night is annoying
let's go it feels like they're gonna get
a pawn back okay now let's go here
this
let's not be too quick to give up
my past be upon
it's just ready to do that
so the first that I'm only been looking
at the different Night Moves
okay
this should be
a safe ground and am I finally ready to
push this Pawn think I am my queen is
also doing a good job
stopping the
the night jumps
they should be pushing through the
Knight is in a pin sort of
now remove this Knight
try to
get to the seventh
okay not so fast
let's go here
controlling the Knight
and finally add this piece to the mix
here here I guess
Queen C6 was probably better just get
rid of the block hater so that these
guys could finally
push on through or at least have an
easier time
pushing through
under 10 for my opponent
gonna get a mover
now let's go in for this now
all right anything should do
okay they're down on time
all right finished with 41 53 41 40.
top three there's your top page I don't
know let's look at the top 50. over a
thousand in here
not too thrilled with how I played
overall
got
wins but
they're
many many messy games
in this hourly super Blitz
a rare time for me to
stream
they're not stream record
anyhow
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
in the comments section below hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care bye